emploi et de l'insertion sur le projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 j'indique que
cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site du Sénat monsieur le
ministre pour notre premier audition sur
la réforme des retraites nous entendions
ce matin monsieur Moscovici sur la vie
du Haut Conseil des finances publiques
nous avons pu déplorer ensemble le
caractère restreint du champ de cet avis
dans la mesure où les informations
transmises par le gouvernement n'ont pas
permis aux conseils d'exposer dans leur
globalité les effets de la réforme
forte de ce retour d'expérience je forme
le vœu que nous rapporteurs soit en
mesure le 1er mars prochain de livrer à
la Commission les éléments dont elle
aura besoin pour se prononcer ce n'est
pas parce que l'inspiration de la
réforme empreinte au désormais fameux
amendement Savary que nous exigences en
trouve à moindre
monsieur le ministre je vais vous
laisser la parole avant que nous
rapporterait Elisabet doit nous
rapporteur général René Paul Savary
rapporteur pour les retraites et Sylvie
verm Meyer rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des finances puis les
commissaires ne vous adressent leurs
questions monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur général Madame et Monsieur
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord peut-être un mot pour
vous dire le plaisir que je vais vous
retrouver pour cette audition début 2023
autour de la réforme des retraites et de
ce texte avant d'en venir au principal
caractéristiques du texte ce qui fait
son identité et ce qui fait aussi les ce
que sont les priorités du gouvernement à
la matière je voudrais peut-être revenir
d'un mot sur la méthode pour dire que
cette réforme telle que nous la
présentons vient après quatre années de
débats sur les retraites vient après 4
mois de concertation nous avons fait le
choix il a maintenant quelques mois avec
le président de la République avec la
première ministre de tenir un nouveau
cycle de concertation et nous avons reçu
chacun des partenaires sociaux chacun
des groupes représentés au Parlement
dans les deux chambres que ce soit
ministère du Travail que ce soit
Matignon à l'occasion de différents
cycles de discussions
c'est une concertation qui a été
fructueuse fructueuse parce que nous
avons pu à la fois et je le dis d'emblée
constater un certain nombre de
désaccords mais aussi nous avons aussi
pu construire des convergences sur un
certain nombre de sujets je précise tout
aussi rapidement que le fait de
rencontrer ou de construire des
convergences sur telle ou tel sujet sur
tel ou telle mesure concernant ici les
carrières longues la question de la
pénibilité n'importe évidemment pas
l'adhésion toute la réforme de la part
de celles et ceux avec lesquels nous
avons échangé et discuté ce qui est
important pour moi de souligner c'est
que l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
sans aucune exception à participer à ses
concertations et jusqu'au bout des
concertations que ce celles que celle
que nous avons organisée directement au
ministère du Travail ou celle que nous
avons organisée avec la chef du
gouvernement
ces réunions donc permis d'avancer sur
un certain nombre de sujets j'y
reviendrai elles ont aussi permis je
pense notamment aux discussions avec des
forces politiques les groupes
parlementaires d'intégrer dès la
présentation du texte un certain nombre
de d'améliorations qui sont le fruit de
travaux parlementaires ou de demande
parlementaires je pense par exemple à la
réparation d'injustice héritée du passé
que nous rassemblons souvent sur
l'appellation des contrats de sucre les
travaux d'utilité collective qui
concernent plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes qui ont ainsi
travaillé entre le milieu des années 80
et le tout début des années 90 et qui
alors qu'elle demande la liquidation de
leurs droits aujourd'hui constate que
ces périodes n'ont pas été
comptabilisées nous allons les réparer
réparer cette anomalie réparer aussi la
même anomalie pour d'autres types de
contrats qui s'apparentait à du travail
mais qui n'était pas assujetti à
cotisation il faut préciser que la
plupart des contrats aidés sont
assujettis à cotisation permettent de
cotiser de valider des trimestres mais
que certaines formes d'emploi comme les
tuques ne l'était pas
nous avons aussi à l'occasion de cette
discussion améliorées je crois le texte
en prévoyant des la présentation dans le
Parlement la revalorisation du niveau
des pensions les plus basses les plus
faibles pensions pour celles et ceux des
retraités qui ont une carrière complète
et ainsi faire en sorte que cette
garantie de retraite minimale à hauteur
de 85 % du SMIC puisse bénéficier non
seulement au nouveau retraités mais
aussi aux actuels retraités nous
estimons qu'il s'agit d'un virgule 8
millions de retraités sur les 17
millions de retraités que nous comptons
aujourd'hui dans le pays qui ainsi
verront cette pension revalorise nous
avons c'est le troisième exemple que je
voulais citer veiller par exemple à
modifier ou à compléter un certain
nombre de dispositions qui concernent
les retraites agricoles la les deux
propositions loi portées par André
Chassaigne ont permis de voter pour les
exploitants la garantie d'une retraite
minimum à 85% du SMIC pour une carrière
complète malheureusement un certain
nombre d'indépendants d'exploitants
agricoles doivent cesser leur carrière
de manière un peu anticipée du fait
d'incapacité physique due à la
pénibilité du métier et ces carrières
achevées prématurément du fait de cette
incapacité ne sont pas réputés complètes
et c'est ainsi que c'est retraités sont
privés du bénéfice de la retraite
minimum de la loi chassé en élargissant
le champ au retraités qui ont fait
valeurs leurs droits à la retraite pour
des raisons d'inaptitudes ou
d'incapacité 145 000 bénéficiaires
nouveaux des garanties châtaignes que
nous allons ainsi permettre
d'accompagner nous aurons aussi à
travailler mais je ne veux pas anticiper
sur les travaux du Sénat des prochains
jours sur
l'examen par votre assemblée je crois
que vous l'avez déjà fait en commission
de l'affaire sociale de la proposition
de loi portée par Monsieur dive
permettant de translater pardon pour
cette Liliane expression le régime des
25 meilleures années que nous
connaissons dans le régime général sur
le régime agricole
j'ai la conviction que nous aurons à
l'occasion des débats l'assemblée puis
ici même au Sénat la possibilité
d'améliorer encore ce texte je pense par
exemple au droit
d'ouvrir des pensions de reversion aux
enfants en situation de handicap qui
perdent leurs parents ou un ça tombe des
chantiers je sais que votre assemblée
est particulièrement auquel je sais
votre assemblée fait particulièrement
attention j'en viens maintenant à la
réforme telle que nous la présentons et
à ses principales caractéristiques c'est
d'abord une réforme d'équilibre puisque
nous avons un double objectif amélioré
notre système de retraite mais aussi
l'équilibré l'équilibré permet de
répondre à une situation nous
connaissons qui est celle exposée dans
le cadre du rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites avec un
déficit à la fois structurel et
prolonger mais aussi accrue d'année en
année du système de retraite lorsque
l'on prend ce rapport du corps et que
l'on le consulte la page 11 était
différente puisque c'est dans cette page
11 il est précisé que quel que soit la
convention et les scénarios retenus et
vous savez toutes les préventions que
nous avons pour une de conventions
utilisées qui n'existe pas dans la
réalité le système est déficitaire sur
les 25 prochaines années et en réalité
parce qu'on regarde la convention
d'équilibre par régime le déficit est
beaucoup plus prolongé et beaucoup plus
prononcé dans l'hypothèse centrale
retenue par le rapport il est de 1,8
milliards et 2023 avant de se creuser à
12,5 milliards en 2027 presque 15 en
2030 et d'atteindre 25 milliards d'euros
par an en 2040 c'est cet aspect
budgétaire finalement qui doit nous
obliger à équilibrer le système nous
sommes absolument convaincus que ne pas
l'équilibrer et finalement d'une
certaine manière le condamner et que
l'attachement que nous avons les uns et
les autres systèmes par répartition doit
nous amener aussi à prendre des
décisions les plus responsables pour que
ce système soit équilibré
je crois aussi que certaines lectures du
rapport du corps sont parfois rapides
quand on ne regarde dans le rapport du
corps que l'évolution des dépenses en
pourcentage de PIB sans tenir compte de
l'évolution des recettes dans le même
temps et donc en inox en ignorant la
dégradation du solde c'est prendre le
risque là aussi de condamner le système
par répartition de fermer les yeux sur
le fait tout simplement qui n'est pas
que les dépenses qui comptent mais les
recettes si un ménage a des dépenses
stables mais des revenus en baisse il y
a fort à parier que le découvert est
plus long terme la faillite le guette et
c'est aussi à cela que nous devons faire
attention
nous voulons aussi pouvoir léguer aux
générations qui viennent un système qui
soit équilibré pour pouvoir leur léguer
tout simplement un système de protection
à la retraite sans être étouffé par une
dette ou assommé par des prélèvements
obligatoires il y a un certain nombre
d'options qui peuvent être discutés il y
avait l'option de diminuer les pensions
elle est inconcevable à nos yeux il y
avait l'option d'augmenter les
prélèvements obligatoires elle serait
contradictoires avec tout ce que nous
faisons depuis maintenant un peu plus de
5 ans pour redonner du souffle à notre
compétitivité au marché du travail au
pouvoir d'achat des Français et donc
nous faisons le choix de l'équilibrer
parce que nous ne voulons pas augmenter
les prélèvements obligatoires et nous ne
voulons pas baisser le pouvoir d'achat
des retraites et nous ne voulons pas non
plus dans le même temps laisser la dette
filer sur les 10 prochaines années cela
serait 150 milliards d'euros de dettes
supplémentaires et dans un pays qui est
déjà lourdement d'été et dans une
période de remontée des taux
obligataires cela nous paraît absolument
inconcevable aussi
aussi pour assurer l'avenir notre
système de retraite nous souhaitons que
nous puissions collectivement travailler
un peu plus longtemps à l'échelle de
chacune de nos vies et ainsi là je
légale sera relevé progressivement comme
vous le savez de trois mois par an à
compter du premier septembre prochain
pour atteindre 63 ans et 3 mois à la fin
du quinquennat et 64 ans 2030 s'ajoute à
cette mesure une accélération de la mise
en oeuvre de la réforme des Touraine à
raison d'un trimestre par an pour
atteindre la durée de cotisation de 43
ans telle qu'elle avait été votée en
2013 à la fin de ce quinquennat
ces mesures finalement ne surprennent
pas véritablement le Sénat puisque elle
rejoignent dans ses modalités un
amendement adopté chaque année par votre
assemblée permettant d'apporter cette
réponse en matière d'équilibre je tiens
à préciser que nous maintenons à 70 ans
l'âge de suppression de la décote c'est
un point important 67 ans peut paraître
aux yeux de tel ou tel et le débat il a
aussi légitime un âge élevé mais à
chaque fois que l'âge de départ à la
retraite a été relevé l'âge de
suppression de la décote a été relevé en
conséquence et ainsi on le maintenance
67 ans nous réduisons la période
d'application de la décote et nous
savons que nous protégeons ainsi de la
décote et d'une des cotes aggravée les
assurés parfois les plus fragiles et
notamment les femmes puisque beaucoup de
celles et ceux qui vont jusqu'à 67 ans
aujourd'hui pour ne pas être exposé à la
décote sont des femmes du fait de
carrière plus hachées que la moyenne
c'est donc un effort en termes de
travail qui est demandé à tous ça n'a
rien indépendant fonctionnaire titulaire
de régime spéciaux pour financer à la
fois le redressement du système et des
mesures de justice et de progrès pour
l'ensemble des retraites et des
retraites cet effort va permettre de
dégager des marges de manœuvre à hauteur
d'environ 18 milliards d'euros en 2030
et ça marche de manœuvre seront
utilisées mobilisées pour les deux tiers
afin de permettre le retour à
l'équilibre du système et pour un tiers
pour financer des mesures nouvelles je
disais que ça allait nous permettre de
financer des mesures de justice et de
progrès les mesures de justice sont la
seconde caractéristique que je veux
souligner à l'occasion de la
présentation du texte il s'agit donc de
travailler plus longtemps mais pas pour
tout le monde et pas de la même manière
ainsi c'est le premier point que je veux
souligner nous voulons mieux prendre en
compte les carrières les plus longues
d'abord en conservant une améliorant le
dispositif tel qu'il existe depuis 2003
et en le rendant peut-être plus juste
c'est plus lisible ainsi lorsque l'âge
légal de départ sera de 64 ans à
l'horizon 2030 il restera comme
aujourd'hui à 58 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans dans
des facilité par rapport à aujourd'hui
puisque nous réduirons la condition de
durée d'assurance exigée il sera à 60
ans pour ceux qui ont commencé entre 16
et 18 ans c'est un nouveau palier que
nous créons et nous faisons aussi en
cohérence avec la promotion de l'entrée
dans la carie carrière professionnelle
par l'apprentissage qui intervient
régulièrement entre 16 et 17 ans il sera
62 ans pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler à cotiser entre 18 et 20 ans
je précise là aussi que le dispositif
permettra de mieux protéger ou d'être
plus ouvert aux femmes en incluant des
périodes de congé parental dans la prise
en compte de la durée requise pour en
bénéficier ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
ce ne sont pas des mesures anecdotiques
ou marginales mais bien les
améliorations substantielles pour le
seul dispositif permettant d'intégrer
des trimestres de congés parental
cotiser au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les parents de les
parents foyers dans les trimestres ainsi
éligibles il faut avoir en tête que un
million 900 000 femmes par an
bénéficient de cette assurance
vieillesse pour les parents au foyer et
que donc parmi elles un nombre assez
considérable vont pouvoir accéder plus
facilement au départ anticipé je précise
aussi pour la transparence et je crois
la sincérité de nos débats que vous ne
trouverez pas dans le pellet FSS rectif
que nous vous présentons de traces de
ces mesures parce qu'elle relève de
nature réglementaire et donc nous les
prendrons par décret par contre dans le
tableau d'équilibre financiers vous
trouverez le coût de ces mesures ce qui
traduit évidemment l'engagement de mise
en oeuvre de ces mesures que le
Gouvernement prend devant le Parlement
le deuxième élément de justice concerne
le maintien de départ anticipées pour
les travailleurs les plus fragiles les
victimes d'accidents et maladies
professionnelles ainsi les personnes
invalides en situation d'inaptitude ou
d'incapacité permanente pourront comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui partir à 62 ans
à taux plein et cela permettra de
maintenir un nombre de départ anticipé
au même niveau qu'aujourd'hui de la même
manière nous voulons faciliter le départ
anticipé des victimes d'accidents du
travail ou de maladies professionnelle
ainsi les victimes d'accidents du
travail ou une maladie professionnelle
et en donnait lieu un taux d'incapacité
supérieure à 20% égale ou supérieur à
20% pour en partir de manière anticipée
de manière automatique sans avis
médicale supplémentaire ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui et nous faciliterons
aussi les conditions de départ pour ceux
qui sont touchés d'un taux d'invalidité
ou d'incapacité supérieure à 10% et
inférieur à 20%
je précise enfin que les travailleurs en
situation d'handicap continueront à
pouvoir partir à partir de 55 ans il y a
aujourd'hui deux conditions cumulatives
et nous allons faire en sorte qu'il n'y
en ait plus qu'une là aussi pour
faciliter l'accès au départ anticipé
pour les travailleurs handicapés et puis
dernier exemple ou d'un point sur ce
sujet les travailleurs exposés à
l'amiante conservant leur départ à
partir de 50 ans comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui ainsi avec ces mesures sur
les carrières longues comme sur les
travailleurs les plus fragiles et
exposés à des troubles ou en tout cas
une forme d'incapacité d'inaptitude ou
de handicap nous renforçons les systèmes
de protection et nous facilitons l'accès
à ces systèmes de protection pour bon
nombre de salariés au global et en
réalité lorsque l'on compare l'âge moyen
de départ effectif par rapport à ce que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
l'augmentation ne sera pas de deux ans
puisque s'agit là de l'augmentation de
l'âge légal de départ mais en réalité
d'un peu plus de 6 mois et pour les
retraités qui ont les pensions les plus
les plus faibles les 20% de pension les
plus faibles souvent bénéficiaires à ces
dispositifs puisqu'il y a causalité le
décalage sera plutôt de l'ordre d'un
trimestre
toujours en matière de justice il nous
faut donner plus de place et plus
importantes au travail des seniors nous
avons dit c'est à la fois une condition
d'atteindre du plein emploi une
condition de réussite de la réforme il y
a un centre de mesure qui ne relève pas
de ce texte en matière de formation en
matière d'accompagnement de l'emploi des
seniors il y a des mesures qui relèvent
très directement de ce texte notamment
pour faciliter les transitions c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous allons
faciliter l'accès à la retraite
progressive deux ans avant l'âge de
l'égal de départ et l'ouvrir à la
fonction publique nous allons aussi
faciliter l'accès au cumul emploi
retraite pour les retraités qui peuvent
qui souhaitent parfois qui doivent
cumuler un emploi avec leur retraite
nous allons faciliter cet accès et nous
allons faire en sorte que ce cumulant
retraite soit contributif puisque
aujourd'hui un retraité qui occupe un
emploi en cumulent avec sa retraite
cotise pour l'assurance vieillesse sans
que ce soit créateur de droit et donc
nous autoriserons une seconde
liquidation pour que les cotisations
versées au titre de ce cumul puisse
permettre une revalorisation du niveau
des retraites que soit les régimes de
base bien sûr nous le souhaitons des
régimes complémentaires
nous allons enfin créer un index un
index senior avec
la volonté de l'appliquer à toutes les
entreprises de plus de 300 salariés la
volonté de le rendre obligatoire pour
ces entreprises depuis 300 salariés et
ainsi nous prévoyons un dispositif de
sanctions financières sur le modèle de
ce qui se fait pour l'index égalité
professionnelle fameuse pour les
entreprises qui se soustraient qui
refuseraient cette obligation de
publicité à l'issue des discussions que
nous avons eu avec les partenaires
sociaux organisation d'employeurs et
organisations syndicale ayant considéré
l'index comme un outil intéressant il
est ressorti une fois le résultat connu
une fois les évolutions connues plutôt
qu'une sanction financière il était plus
utile de prévoir une obligation de
négociation et donc une obligation de
dialogue social une obligation renforcée
c'est ce qui nous amène à intégrer
plutôt à réintégrer la question de
l'emploi des seniors au titre des items
de la gestion des emplois des parcours
professionnels donc avec une obligation
de négociation artérielle
voilà pour la partie justice j'en viens
un certain nombre de progrès que nous
voulons faire à l'occasion de cette
réforme il s'agit d'abord de mieux
prévenir l'usure professionnelle et nous
entendons améliorer la prise en compte
de la pénibilité nous voulons à la fois
faciliter et renforcer l'accès et les
droits acquis au titre du compte
professionnel de prévention le C2P cela
passe par des ajustements notamment
l'abaissement d'un certain nombre de
critères d'éligibilité nous allons par
exemple à baisser de 120 à 100 nuits le
nombre de nuits travaillées par an pour
obtenir des points nous allons mieux
protéger les travailleurs polyposer nous
allons aussi créer une nouvelle
utilisation de droits des points qui sur
le C2P point qui pourrait être acquis de
manière déplafonnée ce qui est aussi une
nouveauté cette nouvelle utilisation
consiste en un congé un congé de
reconversion permettant un salarié
d'arrêter son activité de rester
rémunéré et d'avoir le temps de suivre
une formation qualifiante lui permettant
d'envisager une reconversion et ainsi
une nouvelle orientation qui est
certainement souvent le meilleur moyen
de prévenir la pénibilité les
conséquences de l'usure
nous voulons aussi retravailler sur les
trois critères ergonomiques dont nous
avions constaté en 2017 ils étaient
extrêmement difficiles à mesurer de
manière individuelle en particulier dans
les petites entreprises le porte-charge
lourd des postures pénibles et les
vibrations mécaniques c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous souhaitons à la fois
que les branches professionnelles soient
amenées à négocier des accords de
prévention l'usure professionnelle sur
la base d'une notification par la
branche ATMP des métiers qui sont
considérés comme les plus
potentiellement exposés à la pénibilité
nous savons le faire la branche ATMP le
sait le faire par les taux
d'accidentologie par la prévalence des
maladies professionnelles et en
s'appuyant sur un certain nombre
d'enquêtes comme l'enquête summer qui
permet de déterminer quelles sont ses
métiers les plus exposés pour ces
métiers de l'accord les accords de
prévention ne vont être négociés et
pourront être cofinancés par la branche
ATMP à hauteur d'un milliard d'euros sur
le quinquennat ce qui est en rythme
manuel et cinq fois supérieur à ce que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui en matière
de mobilisation de fonds pour la
prévention de la pénibilité
ces métiers feront aussi l'objet d'un
suivi médical renforcé articulé autour
de la visite médicale professionnelle
que le Parlement a adopté dans le cadre
de la loi santé au travail à 45 ans
d'une nouvelle visite obligatoire à 61
ans qui a un objectif majeur à mes yeux
qui est de permettre pour ceux qui
malheureusement ont connu et souffre des
conséquences de l'usure professionnelle
d'être sûr de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
départ anticipé avant qu'il soit trop
près de la retraite pour pouvoir
bénéficier pleinement de ce droit je dis
en soulignant que la priorité que je
poursuis qui est celle du gouvernement
et je crois de la plupart des forces
politiques et des partenaires sociaux et
de considérer que 100 000 départs
anticipés pour des questions liées à
l'incapacité l'inaptitude et donc pour
des problèmes physiques
n'est pas un chiffre acceptable et nous
ne pouvons pas nous satisfaire
finalement de la réparation je préfère
mille fois je crois que nous sommes
nombreux que les salariés puissent aller
jusqu'à l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite dans de bonnes conditions de
santé et ainsi accéder à la retraite en
bonne santé plutôt qu'avoir des salariés
qui bénéficient dans les parenticipés de
2 ans ou 4 ans mais qui débute le
retrait plutôt avec une santé un
organisme abîmé c'est la raison pour
laquelle la prévention est tout à fait
majeure et reste notre priorité nous
allons cependant là aussi faire en sorte
que ce suivi médical renforcé permette
dès les départs anticipés sous l'angle
de la réparation puisque les dispositifs
de prévention aussi efficaces qu'ils
pourraient être ne permettront jamais
malheureusement de concerner tout le
monde et par ailleurs nous savons qu'il
y a un certain nombre de travailleurs
qui travaillent depuis longtemps dans
ses branches et sont d'ores et déjà
exposés à l'usure et pour lesquelles
l'usure a malheureusement fait son œuvre
deuxième progrès que nous voulons
souligner celui qui concerne
l'augmentation de la pension minimale
nous tenons ainsi un engagement pris par
le Président de la République pendant la
campagne présidentielle qui est de
garantir une pension minimale de 85% du
SMIC pour une carrière complètement
cotisée au niveau du SMIC concrètement
nous allons revaloriser le minimum de
pension de 100 euros par mois à partir
du 1er septembre 2023 pour atteindre
près de 1200 euros par mois pour une
carrière complètement cotisée cela
passera par une revalorisation du
minimum contributif majoré et minimum
contributif de base et nous prévoyons
dans le texte une indexation du minimum
de pension à la liquidation sur le SMIC
pour que cette garantie soit pérenne et
que ce soit une garantie dans le temps
là aussi c'est un effort qu'il faut
souligner puisque on progrès qu'il faut
souligner puisque nous pensons nous
savons même que 200 000 retraités par an
soit un quart des départs à la retraite
bénéficieront d'une revalorisation de
leur pension par rapport à la situation
actuelle et donc bénéficieront par la
réforme d'une pension améliorée et ça
s'applique évidemment au plus petites
pensions
nous allons appliquer je l'ai dit cette
revalorisation pension de retraite
actuelle et cela concerne jusqu'à 1,8
millions de retraités aussi enfin et je
terminerai par là cette réforme est une
team réforme d'équité nous considérons
qu'améliorer la solidarité au sein des
générations et c'est une fête c'est une
certaine manière elle est au bout de la
promesse faite par notre système de
répartition de plus d'équité et c'est
pour cela que nous voulons fermer en
matière de retraite un certain nombre de
régimes spéciaux régimes qui nous
paraissent désormais archaïque ou
générateur d'injustices qui ne sont plus
acceptables et nous fermerons donc pour
ce qui concerne la retraite les régimes
spéciaux de la RATP des industries
électriques et gazières des clercs et
des employés de notaire de la Banque de
France et du Conseil économique social
et environnemental nous le ferons en
respectant le contrat social le pacte
social c'est la raison pour laquelle ces
régimes spéciaux de retraite seront
fermés pour les nouveaux embauchés
uniquement à compter du premier
septembre 2023 par contre l'équité
consiste aussi à demander à l'ensemble
des actifs de travailler un peu plus
longtemps et c'est aussi pour cette
raison que les entreprises qui salariés
des personnels en régime dans le cadre
de régime spéciaux devront ouvrir très
rapidement des négociations pour mettre
en place des périodes de convergence
comme après la réforme de 2010 et ainsi
relever l'âge de départ des régimes
spéciaux de 2 ans comme c'est le cas
pour l'ensemble des salariés
enfin l'équité c'est permettre aux
indépendants d'avoir les mêmes droits
que les salariés face au même montant de
prélèvement et c'est pour ça que
parallèlement à l'examen de ce texte
nous engagerons la réforme de l'assiette
sociale pour la concrétiser dans le
cadre du projet de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 en voyant ce
que les indépendants qui réalisent une
carrière complète bénéficient également
et pleinement de la garantie de retraite
minimale nous avons aussi profité de ce
texte pour solder quelques irritons et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons de stopper définitivement le
processus d'unification du recouvrement
entre l'URSSAF l'agir Carco et la Caisse
des dépôts est consignation voilà madame
la Présidente les principales
caractéristiques du texte je ne doute
pas que sur un certain nombre de publics
de questions il y a des interrogations
que les rapporteurs ou les sénatrices et
sénateurs vont relayer j'essaierai d'y
répondre dans les instants qui suivent
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors on va
prendre les questions des trois
rapporteurs qui commencent
elizabethoineaux
l'auteur général
la présidente monsieur le ministre chers
collègues alors ce n'est pas le moment
c'est ce qu'on entend un peu partout
dans la rue partout dans nos familles
etc en fait nous nous l'avons entendu
depuis 5 ans ici la majorité sénatoriale
présentait cet amendement et on nous
disait d'ailleurs du banc des ministres
que ce n'était pas le moment là c'est le
moment nous sommes
comment la croisée des chemins et et et
nous sommes
dans cette audition et je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre pour toutes les
précisions que vous avez apportées sur
cette réforme des retraites moi je
voudrais le redire nous ne sommes pas
des dogmatiques ici au Sénat pour avoir
défendu depuis 5 ans
ce besoin de de regarder précisément
comment on pouvait agir pour pérenniser
le système de de retraite tel que nous
l'avons depuis un certain temps déjà
cette justice je dirais social sur
laquelle il repose nous ne sommes pas
des dogmatis seulement nous sommes dans
la réalité
des budgets et en fait
nous sommes devant la réalité
démographique et nous savons que nous ne
pouvons pas maintenir en tout cas ce
système de retraite par répartition sans
avoir un regard sur les finances
publiques et permettre que on puisse
conserver ce modèle qui nous est cher
j'ai plusieurs questions d'abord sur les
effets financiers de la réforme sur la
prévention et la réparation de l'usure
professionnelle et en dernier lieu sur
les cotisations ma première question
concernant les effets financiers de la
réforme et celle-ci vous fondez votre la
trajectoire de retour à l'équilibre du
système de retraite à l'horizon 2030
alors on l'a vu sur une perspective de
déficit du système de retraite de 13,5
milliards d'euros à cette échéance mais
de cette prévision repose sur une
hypothèse d'un taux de chômage de 4,5%
aujourd'hui les médias nous annoncent
qu'effectivement on baisse ce taux de
chômage mais est-ce que ce n'est pas
trop optimiste à l'heure où on voit
aussi qu'il y a des défections dans des
entreprises et que le taux de chômage
pour être finalement pas être aussi bas
que prévu est-ce que il n'y a pas lieu
de regarder précisément plusieurs
hypothèses finalement plusieurs scénaris
afin d'être sur de bien faire les choses
est-ce que vous anticipez un autre
scénario en quelque sorte ma deuxième
question sur les effets financiers
pouvez-vous détailler les mécanismes de
solidarité inter-branche que le
gouvernement fait intervenir dans
l'équilibre de la réforme ceci ont-ils
vocation à évoluer voire à être
renforcée à l'occasion de l'examen du
texte
ensuite sur la prévention à la
réparation de l'usure professionnelle
vous avez déjà abordé ce sujet dans vos
propos liminaires mais si vous pouviez
aller un petit peu plus loin vous
prévoyez la création d'un fond
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle financée par la
branche ATMP vous avez annoncé qu'il
serait doté d'un milliard d'euros sur le
quinquennat est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser s'il s'agit de dépenses
nouvelles ou si certaines dépenses de
prévention existence sont réorientées
vers le fond et pour quelles raisons les
facteurs de pénibilité qui seraient pris
en compte au titre du fond inclut que
les risques ergonomiques comme vous les
avez nommé tout à l'heure générateur de
troubles musculoosquelettiques et non
les agents chimiques dangereux alors que
ces derniers sont également exclus du
compte professionnel de prévention le
C2P
pour terminer sur les cotisations
pourquoi reporter au PLFSS pour 2024 la
refonte de l'assiette sociale des
travailleurs indépendants est-ce que
vous pourriez confirmer que l'ensemble
de ces assurés y compris les non
salariés agricoles seront concernés par
cette réforme voilà ce sont mes
questions je ne doute pas que mes
collègues rapporteurs et notamment René
Paul Savary qui voilà était à l'origine
de de tous ces travaux sur la réforme
des retraites sont à même de poser des
questions complémentaires merci monsieur
le ministre
le ministre vous souhaitez répondre déjà
on prend toutes les questions des
rapporteurs alors René Paul René Paul
très bien merci merci effectivement
d'avoir rejoint les propositions de la
majorité
sénatoriale mais nous avions un
calendrier un peu plus modéré que ce qui
est proposé aujourd'hui nous permettront
peut-être de le revoir bien entendu nous
souhaiterions également avoir une étude
d'impact
plus importante me semble-t-il qu'il
doit exister que ce que l'on a jusqu'à
présent si c'était possible puisque nous
avons nous disposons du document de
présentation
[Musique]
et je pense qu'il y a une étude plus
importante d'impact des mesures prises
merci nous les communiquer au plus vite
vous avez déjà répondu à un certain
nombre de questions mais deux trois
précisions comme ça qui nous ont a
priori
sauter aux yeux et qui ne figure pas
forcément directement dans dans le texte
par exemple sur les micros entrepreneurs
puisque certains sont avisés
à la caisse régime général mais donc
vont par exemple bénéficier des
dispositions du minimum contributif
alors que ceux qui sont reliés restés à
la CIPAV semble-t-il ne bénéficierait
pas des minimum contributifs
c'est peut-être un point à lever
également en ce qui concerne ce minimum
contributif allez-vous faire participer
les régimes complémentaires puisque
c'est un une allocation différencielle
qui prend en compte justement les
pensions des régimes de base et
complémentaires et qu'elle est votre
stratégie dans ce domaine là en ce qui
concerne l'usure professionnelle
il y a la visite médicale qui est tout à
fait intéressante entre 60 61 ans je
pense même qu'elle devrait être
peut-être de façon plus antérieure
qu'elle peut être plus complète qu'une
visite médicale mais c'est très bien
pour ceux qui sont en emploi mais ceux
qui ne sont pas en emploi et on sait
qu'il y en a qui ne sont pas en emploi
quelle mesure avez-vous allez vous
proposer pour effectivement qu'il puisse
bénéficier également de d'une entrevue
médicale ou sociale permettant de
redéfinir la trajectoire de fin d'emploi
de ces personnes là en ce qui concerne
également l'emploi des seniors est-ce
que vous prévoyez une loi travail pour
définir un certain nombre de mesures
parallèlement à ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui qui est une loi plus
budgétaire bien entendu qui prescrit un
certain nombre de dispositifs nous avons
besoin là aussi
une vision dans l'avenir pour voir si
nous faisons ou pas un certain nombre de
propositions en ce qui concerne
maintenant les départs anticipés en
retraite effectivement vous avez émis
trois critères 16 18 20 ans mais pour
les 16-18 ans 44 années de cotisation
pour ceux qui sont à compter de la
génération
1965 est-ce que ce dispositif peut être
me semble enfin ce dispositif me
semble-t-il peut être éventuellement
modifié puisque il est difficile de
expliquer à ces générations qu'il
travailleront qui sont une durée
d'emploi plus longue que les autres me
semble-t-il et là aussi je pense qu'il y
a des dispositions qui peuvent peut-être
être prises peut-être en avez-vous déjà
envisagé de même vous dites que en ce
qui concerne les carrières actives euh
il n'est plus nécessaire de finir dans
l'emploi caractérisant la carrière
active pour pouvoir bénéficier de ses
avantages or il nous semblerait que ça
existe déjà et que celui qui a une
carrière active qui reprend une carrière
qui n'est pas éligible au régime des
actifs puissent bénéficier quand même
des avantages qu'il a eu c'est en tout
cas les réponses que nous font un
certain nombre de caisses et notamment
les centres de gestion également de la
fonction publique territoriale qui nous
disent qu'il n'est pas nécessaire que le
fonctionnaire termine sa carrière sur un
emploi relevant de la caractérise la
catégorie active pour bénéficier du
départ anticipé dans le cadre de ce
dispositif
donc là aussi cela mérite quelques
précisions merci de nous les apporter
merci
de m'avoir permis de d'assister à cette
audition et de poser des questions sur
le ministre remercie pour votre
présentation je vais ajouter quelques
questions à celle de mes collègues tout
d'abord pour ce qui concerne l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme au 1er septembre
j'ai déjà des retours
de la part de certaines catégories ou de
collectivités qui font valoir que une
application aussi rapide une entrée en
vigueur aussi rapide de la réforme
complique parce que les projections des
entreprises ou des collectivités je
pense aussi aux enseignants qui ne
peuvent pas partir en cours d'année
compliqué énormément il y a le fait de
pouvoir prendre ses congés lorsqu'on
fait valoir ses droits à la retraite les
comptes épargne tant et le tuilage entre
le remplaçant qui doit reprendre le
poste et le départ du retraité fait que
on s'y souvent un an à l'avance et
qu'une application une entrée en vigueur
de la réforme au 1er septembre 2023
parait très très rapide et en tout cas
risque de compliquer le l'organisation
et le coût pour ceux qui se sont déjà
organisés pour remplacer des départs à
la retraite
une interrogation sur les perspectives
et les cotisations dans le prolongement
de des interrogations d'Élisabeth
Doisneau dans le cadre du projet de loi
sur il avait été envisagé de d'avoir une
cotisation vieillesse des plafonnée
est-ce que on a une idée de ce que
pourrait donner une cotisation
vieillesse au-delà du plafond de la
sécurité sociale par exemple jusqu'à 3
passes
concernant la revalorisation des minimas
1200 euros du SMIC brut
est-ce que ça concerne bien les
polypensionnés c'est une une
confirmation que j'aimerais avoir
concernant les régimes spéciaux
sujets qui me tient à coeur
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
quelques précisions sur ce qui va
advenir des régimes spéciaux
est-ce que les nouveaux affiliés
rentrant cotisants à la CNAV et
agircours est-ce qu'on peut imaginer des
compensations des conventions de
compensation entre
la CNAV et comme ça c'est fait
finalement pour la SNCF des
compensations qui permettraient de
rendre une cotisations des nouveaux
entrants pour pouvoir financer les les
pensions également quel est le devenir
par exemple je pense à la Banque de
France de leur du solde de la caisse
pour ça représente tout de même un peu
plus de 15 milliards pour la Banque de
France qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez pour
ce le devenir de cette caisse
ensuite un sujet important qui concerne
la natalité le taux de fécondité est-ce
que vous prévoyez des mesures qui aille
au-delà de ce qui existe aujourd'hui en
matière de maternité
pour encourager en tout cas
ne pas
dissuader les femmes d'avoir des enfants
je pense qu'on ne peut pas rétablir un
système de retraite par répartition
sans inverser cette courbe décroissante
du nombre d'actifs et en tout cas
soutenir le rythme des générations
voilà de cette de cette manière est-ce
que vous envisagez des des actions
complémentaires et puis de façon tout à
fait liée quel serait le devenir du
Fonds de réserve des retraites se font
de réserves des retraites à mes yeux
devrait être sanctuarisés tout
simplement pour pouvoir
engranger des excédents quand ce serait
le cas et se prémunir de futurs choc
démographique tels que celui qu'on est
en train de connaître
dernier point on est ici au Sénat vous
me permettrez d'avoir une attention
que je porte depuis 5 ans avec ma
mission de rapporteur c'est celle de la
retraite des élus et notamment les élus
qui perçoivent des indemnités
inférieures à la moitié du plafond de la
sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire
1833 euros aujourd'hui depuis 2013 les
élus qui perçoivent plus de la moitié du
plafond de la sécurité sociale cotise à
toutes les cotisations
et donc la cotisation vieillesse la
cotisation de base en cela il conserve
des droits à la retraite plein et
entiers et ils peuvent faire valoir
leur carrière pleinement ceux qui sont
en dessous de la moitié du plafond de la
sécurité sociale ne cotise casser gcrds
et à l'ircantheque retraite
complémentaire mais ne cotise pas à la
retraite de base et je trouve que c'est
une parce qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
de mères ou d'adjoint d'élus qui
réduisent leur temps de travail pour
pouvoir exercer cette fonction de maire
ou d'adjoint et en ça perdent des droits
à la retraite puisqu'ils ont une
cotisation de base plus faible et le
pire pour moi c'est que lorsqu'ils font
valoir leur droit à la retraite ils ne
peuvent même pas prétendre à racheter
des trimestres et ça ça me semble
profondément injuste on permettrait un
parallèle
quelqu'un qui a fait de la prison a le
droit de racheter des trimestres pas un
maire dans ce cadre là je trouve que
c'est profondément injuste et j'espère
que ce texte pourra remédier à cette
injustice merci
ce ministre beaucoup de questions
une pose dans les questions
très merci madame la Présidente et merci
mesdames et Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteur peut-être dans l'ordre des
questions telles qu'elles ont été
abordées sur la question des équilibres
financiers et des effets financiers de
la réforme nous prévoyons effectivement
un retour à l'équilibre en 2030 avec une
hypothèse de chômage qui est la 4,5% en
2027 il n'y pesait une hypothèse de
productivité moyenne c'est en cela
qu'une qualifions l'hypothèse de
centrale vous avez raison de considérer
que le taux de 4,5% de chômage est
obligé est optimiste et c'est l'objet de
tous nos efforts mais il reste optimiste
le besoin de mener des politiques
d'emplois très actives si le taux de
chômage était moins bas et si la
situation était moins améliorée que nous
l'espérons évidemment ça se traduirait
par des déficits plus importants
au même horizon et une difficulté plus
importante d'atteindre l'objectif à cet
horizon nécessitant peut-être de décaler
un peu la date de retour à l'équilibre
mais il nous a semblé cependant
difficile d'aller au-delà et d'anticiper
un scénario plus pessimiste parce que
les mesures tombaient en place doivent
pouvoir l'aide de manière progressive et
anticiper un scénario plus sur un
scénario plus pessimiste nous aurez
conduit à des mesures qu'on qualifie par
de paramétrer plus rapidement et plus
importantes ce qui aurait été à
difficile à mettre en œuvre
la solidarité la solidarité interbranche
va intervenir de la manière suivante
nous constatons et ça fait le lien avec
votre question suivante que la branche
ATMP elle a caractéristique extrêmement
agréable d'être particulièrement
excédentaire à horizon 2026 nous
estimons que l'excédent sera 3,3
milliards d'euros une fois retraité les
virements au titre de la solidarité
inter-branche qui sont
traditionnellement adoptées en PLFSS
autour d'un milliard un milliard centres
des sous-décrations pour les accidents
du travail et donc après ce retraitement
il reste 3,3 milliards d'euros si nous
nous considérons que la mobilisation de
nouveaux moyens pour le fonds prévention
l'usure professionnelle mobilise 200
millions d'euros sur 3,3 milliards
d'euros il reste 3900 par définition et
si nous diminuions la cotisation ATMP
versée par les employeurs pour environ
un milliard d'euros
cela permet de garder un excédent autour
de 2 milliards ce qui est sur une caisse
de caisse à une branche à TMP j'ai rendu
7 milliards par an un excédent qui reste
tout à fait
raisonnable et même confortable et cette
diminution de la cotisation ATMP hauteur
d'un milliard d'euros serait compensé
par une augmentation de la cotisation
CNAV des employeurs de 0,12 points
représentant un milliards d'euros aussi
c'est notre pour l'employeur c'est notre
pour les employeurs mais ça permet par
contre de générer un milliard d'euros de
recettes au titre de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse et ainsi dans les
bornes du système de retraite de
participer à l'équilibre et à cette
atteinte d'objectif d'équilibre les
risques
ergonomiques sont la priorité des
accords de prévention l'usure
professionnelle mais bien évidemment
nous serons ouverts dans le cadre des
négociations pour voir quels sont les
autres risques qui pourraient être ainsi
prévenu
je fais juste une parenthèse pour dire
que l'exposition aux agents chimiques
est évidemment un point qu'il ne faut
pas sous-estimer nous considérons mais
tout à fait ouvert évidemment au débat
sur ce point là que sur les questions
d'agents chimique la question ne doit
pas être réglée en terme de prévention
sur site de travail ou de réparation
mais doivent avant tout être réglés par
des normes d'interdiction et pour
empêcher cette exposition c'est la
raison pour laquelle pour nous cela
arrive plus de la sécurité que de la
pénibilité et c'est la raison aussi pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas réintégré de
la même manière ce risque lié à
l'exposition au risque chimiques enfin
Madame la rapporteur général vous avez
évoqué la question de la refonte de
l'assiette sociale de cotisations
sociales des indépendants nous n'avons
pas inscrit dans ce texte puisqu'il
s'agit d'une loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative et nous
savons que cette modification de
l'assiette n'aura pas d'effet sur les
comptes sociaux de 2023 ce qui rend sa
mesure la mesure en tant que tel il
recevable à l'instant nous discutons et
surtout nous avons besoin d'un travail
technique pour le mener et dans les
délais qui sont les nôtres il n'auraient
pas été possible pour ce qui concerne
les indépendants toujours nous avons un
travail qui est ouvert avec les
partenaires sociaux et en particulier
ceux des partenaires sociaux côté
employeurs qui sont les plus impliqués
dans la gestion de la caisse de
protection sociale et travailleur
indépendants de manière à veiller à ce
que les meilleurs protections soient
abordées et accordées ça fait l'objet
d'instructions techniques qui sont en
cours une réunion de travail de mon
cabinet et des équipes de la principale
organisation d'employeur si Jean au sein
de la CPST en l'occurrence la CPME
encore eu lieu cette semaine pour voir
justement comment avancer sur ces sujets
là qui ne relèvent pas du législatif
mais parfois du réglementaire ou encore
d'autorisation ministérielle donnée sur
l'engagement tel ou tel dépense sur le
modèle de ce que nous avions fait
pendant la crise du covid lorsque la
même cpsti avait souhaité accorder une
aide sociale aux indépendants
complémentaires des mesures d'urgence
prises par le gouvernement et la
sécurité sociale et enfin les
pour le domaine de l'agriculture j'ai
évoqué la situation des non salariés
mais il évidemment la question des
salariés agricoles qui bénéficieront
pleinement des mesures au même titre et
de manière analogue au régime général
monsieur le rapporteur Savary vous avez
évoqué la question de l'étude d'impact
ça me permet simplement d'apporter une
précision mais purement méthodologique
nous sommes dans le cas d'un bel effet
SSS rectif et donc formellement il n'y a
pas d'étude d'impact comme pour un
projet de Loire nous avons souhaité à la
fois pour éclairer les débats et ouvrir
un centre de discussions
fournir au Parlement et à tous ceux que
cela intéresse par ailleurs un rapport
d'évaluation qui est le document que
vous évoquez mais nous avons aussi une
obligation qui est de fournir une fiche
d'impact sur chacune des mesures du
pvfss comme pour tout LFSS
ces documents ont été normalement
transmis par le satariat général du
gouvernement aux deux assemblées en tout
cas ça a été le cas pour l'Assemblée
nationale je vais m'assurer que ce soit
le cas pour le Sénat bien évidemment
mais si ça n'était pas le cas il est là
en version papier nous vous le passerons
très directement pour que vous puissiez
en prendre en prendre connaissance pour
ce qui concerne la CIPAV les professions
libérales et les micro-entrepreneurs il
n'y a pas d'application pour ce qui les
concerne de la garantie à 85% du SMIC
pour une raison c'est qu'il s'agit de
régime particulier que vous avez rappelé
sur pour certains obligatoires et pour
d'autres sur d'autres option et que ces
régimes n'ont jamais mis en place de
minimum de pension et donc il est
difficile de mettre en place un
mécanisme de relèvement d'un minimum de
pension qui n'existe pas c'est la raison
pour laquelle à date c'est peut-être un
point à travailler avec eux il y a cette
possibilité les régimes complémentaires
ne seront pas mises à contribution
directement puisque nous procédons par
augmentation du mico dans sa partie
majorée comme dans sa partie de base et
donc il s'agit pas d'une allocation ou
d'une garantie différentielle mais bien
d'un relèvement du niveau du minimum
pension au niveau du régime de base pour
atteindre les 85% du SMIC comme je l'ai
indiqué
vous avez ensuite souhaité savoir si
pour un certain nombre de mesures
notamment sur l'emploi des seniors les
questions relatives à la formation les
concernant un texte législatif haute que
ce bel effet s rectif était prévu je
vous le confirme et d'ici l'été nous
aurons l'occasion de proposer au
Parlement l'examen d'un autre texte sur
l'emploi elle travaille et qui aura
aussi vocation apporter un centre de
mesure dans le cadre de la mise en
oeuvre de France travail de
l'accompagnement amélioré renforcé des
allocataires du RSA ou encore pour
donner suite aux propositions qui ont
été faites dans le cadre des discussions
entre partenaires sociaux sur la
formation professionnelle et donc ça
nous permettra aussi de compléter autant
que nécessaire l'ouvrage c'est des
mesures n'étaient pas recevables en
PLFSS
vous avez enfin évoqué deux sujets la
question des catégories actives je vous
confirme que vous avez raison et moi
aussi d'abord parce que un certain
nombre de cadres d'emploi de la fonction
publique territoriale et de corde en
plein Delta ne sont pas assujettis à la
clause d'achèvement mais il y a des
corps d'emploi de l'État en particulier
qui sont assujettis à cette clause
d'achèvement et en supprimant cette
clause d'achèvement nous permettront à
tout agent public travaillant dans un
corps une catégorie active de pouvoir
finir sa carrière sur un métier qualifié
de sédentaire sans perdre les droits au
départ anticipé
vous avez évoqué ensuite la question de
la durée de cotisation ça me permet de
revenir sur un débat qui a traversé
l'opinion publique la classe politique
au tout cours des derniers jours la
réforme du Touraine de 2013 a prévu il y
a 10 ans maintenant le passage de 42 à
43 années de cotisation et nous en
accélérons la mise en œuvre
nous avons proposons un certain nombre
de dispositifs relatif au carrière
longue j'ai dit tout à l'heure que nous
simplifions l'accès
au départ anticipé pour ceux qui ont
cotisé 5 trimestres avant 16 ans qui
sont assez rares et c'est finalement
tant mieux ça signifie que les périodes
de formation et d'enseignement sont
ainsi respectés actuellement dans le
système tel qu'il est écrit pour
bénéficier de ce départ à 58 ans il faut
non seulement avoir travaillé cinq
trimestres avant 16 ans mais présenter
une durée de cotisations égales à la
durée minimum obligatoire plus deux ans
que nous ramenons à un nom y compris
pour tenir compte d'ailleurs de la mise
en oeuvre progressive de la réforme
Touraine les dispositifs que nous
proposons permettent en réalité de
rapprocher et de diminuer l'écart entre
la durée de cotisation minimum exigée
exigée pour avoir une pension à taux
plein et la durée de cotisation
effective des différents actifs cet
écart a pu être très important lorsque
les carrières longues n'existaient pas
avant 2003 avec un âge de départ à la
retraite et alors que nous étions à 37,5
années celles et ceux qui commençaient à
15 ans à 16 ans travailler jusqu'à 45
ans pour avoir droit à une retraite à
taux plein à 60 ans
alors que il était exigé 37,5 années de
cotisations et donc l'écart pouvaient
être de 8 ans entre la durée minimum
requise et la durée que certains étaient
obligés de travailler pour accéder à la
retraite aujourd'hui nous serons entre
43 et 44 ans parfois 44 ans et 3 mois et
ça me permet de souligner en écho des
bas qui a lieu sur cette aspect 43 à 44
années que la durée d'affiliation au
régime pour bénéficier d'une tension à
taux plein n'a jamais été un plafond
dans le système de retraite tel que nous
le connaissons mais bien un minimum et
un plancher et aujourd'hui dans le
système tel qu'il fonctionne sur les
deux sur les 800 000 presque 800 000
départs à la retraite par an 180000 sont
des départs d'assurés qui ont plus de
trimestres que le minimum requis pour
bénéficier du taux plein je le dis sans
dire que tout est parfait la perfection
n'existe pas en la matière mais pour
dire que cette situation un certain
nombre d'assurés sont amenés à
travailler un tout petit peu plus
longtemps que la durée minimum exigée
une session que nous connaissons et nous
réduisons de manière forte aussi plus
forte que ce n'était le cas l'écart
entre celles et ceux qui doivent
commence à travailler tôt et celles et
ceux qui commencent à travailler plus
tard j'en viens en question de madame le
rapporteur Vernier pour dire que le
délai de six mois de mise en oeuvre de
la réforme que nous souhaitons mettre en
mettre en place le délai classique pour
les ce qui concerne la mise en oeuvre
des réformes de retraite qui nous permet
à la fois d'atteindre les objectifs de
d'équilibre et de mise en œuvre de la
réforme qui sont les nôtres en précisant
que le relèvement de trois mois de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits au 1er septembre
n'est pas la seule mesure qui entre en
vigueur le 1er septembre la mesure
concernant le minimum de pension pour le
stock comme pour le flux la mesure
concernant les carrières longues toutes
les mesures que j'ai annoncées qui
apparaissent comme des mesures de
progrès de justice d'amélioration des
droits sont aussi mis en oeuvre dès le
1er septembre et il y a cette
concordance de temps qui nous faut pour
ce qui concerne le déplafonnement de
cotisations nous ne souhaitons pas aller
plus loin que ce qui existe c'est-à-dire
la possibilité d'aller 2,3% d'avoir une
cotisation de 2,3% au dessus du du
plafond de sécurité sociale puisque la
mesure que vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure s'inscrivait bien dans un
système universel d'acquisition de
points et fonctionne moins bien dans un
système qui reste fondé sur
l'acquisition et la validation de
trimestre pour les polypensionnés je
vous confirme qu'ils seront éligibles au
minimum de pension je porte peut-être
une nuance mais que j'apporte sous forme
d'interrogations pour vous répondre plus
tard ce que je fais quoi la question de
Monsieur Savary sur des polypes
pensionnés qui auraient une partie de
leur carrière sur la 6e par exemple donc
il faut qu'on regarde je ne sais pas
vous dire si c'est le cas comment ça
fonctionne pour eux les gars à la
réponse que j'ai apporté à monsieur le
rapporteur sur les régimes spéciaux il
n'y a aucun risque sur la pérennité et
la soutenabilité financière pour ce qui
les concerne et les flux qui sont à
organiser comme vous l'avez noté le
seront dans le cas du PLFSS 2024 pour la
mise en oeuvre de la réforme une fois
celle-ci en train en vigueur c'est même
régime qu'il soit régime spéciaux ou
régime autonome conserve la pleine
possession de la réserve puisque le fait
de ne pas être dans un système universel
ne pose pas la question de la
mutualisation des réserves
enfin sur les droits familiaux nous
avons prévu un certain nombre de mesures
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
création d'une assurance vieillesse pour
les aidons l'intégration la prise en
compte de trimestres de la VPF pour les
éligibilité au départ anticipé carrière
longue ou
l'éligibilité au minimum de pension
il y a je le sais des attentes sur
certains aspects de la pension de
réversion puis je crois qu'il y a un
temps très partagé au Sénat comme à
l'Assemblée nationale d'harmonisation
des droits je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
lors des questions au Gouvernement la
maternité permet de valider quatre
trimestres au titre du régime général de
au titre de la fonction publique cela
pouvait s'expliquer lorsqu'elle est
carré la fonction publique étaient
beaucoup plus linéaire que celle du
privé ça s'explique certainement moins
aujourd'hui les trimestres de maternité
étaient liés à des interruptions
d'activité aujourd'hui nous savons qu'il
peut y avoir cumul de validation
trimestre pendant la même période du
fait des systèmes d'indemnisation des
périodes de congé maternité et donc il y
a certainement un travail assez long et
assez complet à faire et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons souhaité que le
préoccupe je ne doute pas que les
parlementaires seront force de
proposition sur le fond de réserve nous
ne le touchons pas il est
malheureusement très bas puisqu'il est
autour de 5 milliards d'euros mais ça
n'est pas un objet autre de débat à nos
yeux enfin pour la question des élus il
y a un centre de dispositions qui ont
été prises que vous avez rappelé il y a
une lettre ministre de mars 2022 qui a
permis de régler aussi quelques
situations il faut que nous puissions
travailler et vraiment c'est une
ouverture de ma part mais je sais que le
débat nous permettra d'avancer sur la
question du rachat de trimestre parce
que c'est vrai que c'est une injustice
c'est que si nous trouvons un moyen de
permettre le rachat de trimestre
non cotisé du fait de l'exercice de
mandat ça serait une possibilité de
réparer cette inégalité de traitement
entre celle et ceux qui peuvent racheter
des trimestres et ceux qui ne le peuvent
pas
merci beaucoup alors nous allons
attaquer le reste des questions
monsieur
valerenberg ensuite Monique Lubin mais
la niveau gel Corinne Ferret on verra
sur s'arrête là pour vous répondez aussi
on continue et encore quatre
commissaires ensuite Jean-Marie
merci Madame ma présidente sur le
ministre je voudrais tout d'abord vous
remercier
des bilans que vous détape que vous avez
organisé auquel nous avons pu participer
de la masse d'information que vous nous
avez donnée
des effectivement des bilans financiers
que vous aviez esquissé même si les
regrettable qu'on n'est pas aujourd'hui
l'étude d'impact pour être beaucoup plus
précis
je suis pour ma part avec mon groupe
tout à fait d'accord sur la nécessité
d'engager cette réforme
on le sait on le regarde c'est parfois
controversé mais les études du corps
sont très claires même s'il y a parfois
des phrases un peu alambiquées qui fasse
qui introduisent des doutes je ne les
partage pas pour ma part j'ai lu ce
rapport puisque nous participons avec un
certain nombre d'entre nous à ces
travaux
et il est clair que si on ne fait rien
le cumul des déficits va nous emmener à
une dette abyssale de plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros en 2050
alors je ne peux pas imaginer que le
Sénat puisse laisser passer cela sans
rien sans réagir
alors j'en viens à quelques questions si
vous voulez bien rapidement
je voudrais être que qu'on soit très
précis sur les mesures sociales que vous
avez envisagées pas toutes parce que je
n'ai pas tout balayé mais pour la
retraite minimum vous parlez de 1200
euros brut mais en faisant référence aux
85% du SMIC net qui est on sait de 1150
environ 150 euros aujourd'hui alors
c'est introduit enfin une suspicion
vous le comprendrez donc j'aimerais que
vous soyez très clair sur ce point
sur les carrières longues moi je
regrette pour ma part qu'on vous dit que
les bandes de linge seront fixées par
décret mais on fait allusion à 44 ans
alors que le principe même c'est en 2027
d'être à 43 années de cotisation à ce
qu'on pourrait pas imaginer qu'avant 20
ans tous ceux qui ont travaillé avant 20
ans puisse partir avec les 43 années
effectivement de cotisations sur la
pénibilité est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer que les trois critères di
ergonomiques qui sont ajoutées
donneront et ouvriront des droits
nouveaux
en point comptabilisé en point dans le
C2P et
je dis puisqu'on déplaphone
est-ce que et qu'on est dans la loi
retraite réforme des retraites est-ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas imaginer que les
10 points supplémentaires au dessus de
100 puissent ouvrir effectivement des
trimestres de départ pour le départ
anticipé le trimestre de supplémentaire
sur les droits familiaux et conjugaux il
y a un point qui me paraît évident c'est
qu'il y a une harmonisation nécessaire
entre le privé et le public
les droits sont pas les mêmes vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure c'est deux
mois d'un côté c'est 8 mois de l'autre
donc je pense que
la première des mesures ce serait
celle-là une mesure de justice
et puis je terminerai sur les recettes
en m'interrogeant d'ailleurs sur les
dépenses comment allons-nous pouvoir
introduire des amendements avec
l'article 40
donc j'attends de votre part un esprit
d'ouverture
à nul autre pareil sinon on est
complètement bloqué tout ce que je vous
dis là ça sert à rien
on peut pas avancer donc comme vous avez
dit qu'il s'agissait de construire la
loi avec le Parlement
pouvez-vous nous dire comment vous allez
faire sur les recettes thermiques
moi je pense qu'il faut une clause
d'envoyer en 2027
les bases vous l'avez rappelé elles sont
aujourd'hui quand même aujourd'hui un
peu difficile à vérité véritablement
confirmé
les scénarios peuvent varier avec
notamment la productivité le taux de
chômage la croissance donc il me semble
nécessaire de vérifier 2027 où nous en
sommes je pense que
vous parlez d'un équilibre en 2030
il me serait nécessaire pour moi
nécessaire de vérifier en 2027 si on est
sur la bonne trajectoire et si par
hasard nous étions au dessus de la
trajectoire ce serait peut-être
utile de suivre d'ailleurs les
recommandations du Sénat et c'est de
devoir l'horizon 64 ans beaucoup plus
tardivement
s'il était nécessaire d'ailleurs de
poursuivre sur cette dans cette
direction sur et je vais vous donner
quand même une ou deux pin's de recettes
supplémentaires je sais que vous avez
avec le gouvernement fermé complètement
le
droit
je termine je termine
vous avez fermé complètement la porte au
taux de cotisation
employeur je rappelle quand même vous
l'avez donné les chiffres que 1%
rapporterait 9 milliards environ pour 30
millions de cotisants vous avez
effectivement si vous n'en prenez même
qu'un tiers 3 milliards 3 milliards
c'est quand même considérable et c'est
peu c'est 100 euros moi j'ai calculé
tout simplement c'est 100 euros par
salarié par an
pour une entreprise de 10 salariés 1000
euros
c'est trois fois rien donc alors il y a
une autre piste vous l'avez indiqué vous
dites on va transférer des droits de la
TNT vers effectivement la branche
vieillesse il y a peut-être aussi un
milliard qui sont aujourd'hui transférés
à l'assurance maladie pourrait s'ajouter
aussi à la brancheviere le milliard de
l'Assurance Maladie vous le savez
parfaitement on en a souvent parlé la
fraude la fraude à l'assurance maladie
elle est tellement importante qu'elle
pourrait faire facilement évidemment
compenser ce milliard voilà sur j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure sur les seniors
000 emplois ça rapporte un milliard je
pense qu'en 2027 on devrait être
facilement à 2 milliards supplémentaires
voilà quelques pistes monsieur le
ministre que je vous suggère
Monique Lubin Mélanie pochel Corinne
Ferrer Montaigne Xavier yakovelli
Philippe Jacquemin Monique Lubin merci
madame la Présidente bon moi je
m'étonnerait pas sur certains nombre de
choses que j'ai envie de dire nous
aurons quelques jours de débat et donc
nous aurons l'occasion de dire ce que
nous avons envie de dire
j'ai quelques questions pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas fait un véritable projet
de loi sur les retraites parce que
toutes les mesures d'accompagnement
dont vous nous parlez soit vous nous
dites qu'elles seront prises par décret
et décréant c'est ce qu'il en est soyez
ne sont jamais pris soit ils nous
réserve certaines surprises comme la
surprise qu'on a eu le 23 décembre avec
le décret qui finalement n'a pas été
pris sur l'indemnisation des chômeurs
ou alors vous nous dites que il y aura
une mesure une projet de loi oui ça vous
fait beaucoup rire excusez-moi
pas ça pourtant très rigolo et donc
soit il y aura un projet de loi
supplémentaire bon enfin voilà
alors en fait vous pose la question mais
je sais bien pourquoi vous n'avez pas
fait un projet de loi retraite et
pourquoi vous êtes passé par une loi de
finance rectificative pour des raisons
uniquement de de politique politicienne
mais c'est bien dommage quand même parce
que les salariés les futurs retraités
mieux que ça sur les questions pratiques
le fait de reculer l'âge à 64 ans va
susciter quelques économies en termes de
surcote puisqu'on a des salariés qui
auraient pu bénéficier du surcote et qui
n'en n'auront plus est-ce que vous
envisagez du coup
d'améliorer le système de décote et
notamment pourquoi pas pour les femmes
sur l'apprentissage la loi Touraine
avait permis a permis
aux apprentis enfin à ceux qui ont été
apprentis de faire en sorte que leur que
les trimestres d'apprentissage compte
pour la retraite mais c'est depuis 2014
est-ce que on peut envisager
de prendre en compte les trimestres
d'apprentissage
pour les années antérieures
vous avez parlé des tucs je sais que
vous avez il y a eu une mission à
l'Assemblée nationale et je fais partie
des gens qui qui ont été saisis comme
d'autres sur les tucs vous allez les
prendre en fin vous allez leur donner
des droits à retraite ce qui est bien
dans quelles conditions
les bonifications pour enfants
et femmes aujourd'hui bénéficient de 8
trimestres par enfant
ça les aide pour un certain pour un
grand nombre d'entre elles à avoir les
carrières à taux plein à pouvoir partir
à la retraite à l'âge légal avec des
carrières à taux plein
pour un certain nombre d'entre elles du
coup qui devront travailler un peu plus
finalement c'est bonification pour
enfants c'est trimestre supplémentaire
ne trouveront plus leur utilité donc que
restera-t-il finalement pour pour les
femmes qui qui comment dire qui avait
comme bon alors je sais pas comment il
faut appeler ça compensation
ces trimestres pour finalement les les
mois qu'elles avaient passé à s'occuper
de leurs enfants est-ce qu'on peut
envisager donc une autre forme pour pour
les femmes une autre forme de
de soutien comme ça a été dit d'ailleurs
à la maternité
et enfin moi j'avoue aussi que je ne
comprends pas bien j'ai besoin d'une
explication technique sur les 1200 euros
parce que moi j'avais cru comprendre que
c'était donc une augmentation à 85 % du
SMIC
de la retraite donc retraite principale
plus retraite complémentaire donc avec
un appel aux caisses de retraite
complémentaire et maintenant j'entends
parler de minimum contributifs j'avoue
que je comprends pas là j'ai besoin
d'une vraiment techniquement d'une
explication merci
merci Madame un présidente monsieur le
ministre je crois que ma question va va
bien avec la dernière question de ma
collègue parce que ma première question
est exactement sur cette affaire de des
1200 euros le gouvernement a beaucoup
communiqué sur le fait que dans cette
réforme il y avait un équilibre éco au
fond des sacrifices étaient nécessaires
pour rétablir le niveau des petites
retraites notamment autour de cet
exemple phare d'une personne fictive je
crois dans mes souvenirs qu'elle
s'appelait Hélène mais je crois qu'elle
n'existe pas qui pouvait bénéficier
qui pouvait bénéficier d'une hausse à
hauteur donc de 85% du SMIC soit 1200
euros après avoir cotisé toute sa vie au
SMIC avec une carrière complète bon déjà
de ce que je comprends c'est pas 1200
mais 1193 je sais que pour certains 7
euros c'est pas grand chose voire rien
mais pour d'autres personnes c'est
beaucoup
précision mis de côté sur les 7 euros
depuis ce que j'ai compris c'est qu'en
réalité c'est pas exactement la réalité
et que beaucoup de personnes qui
seraient touchées par cette hausse du
minimum contributif n'arriverait pas à
la fin avec une paire mais avec une
pension qui serait à hauteur de 1200
euros donc moi je voudrais savoir
quelque chose de très simple est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire non pas combien de
personnes vont être touchées par le
dispositif non pas combien de personnes
vont voir le minimum contributif
réhausser mais combien de personnes
touchées par le dispositif vont se
retrouver à la fin après cette avec une
retraite à hauteur de 1200 euros je
pense que c'est un chiffre assez simple
qui est important à connaître puisque
c'est présenté comme étant une des
mesures positives de cette réforme et ce
serait important de savoir combien de
personnes vont être touchées la deuxième
question c'était sur un sujet qui a
beaucoup qui a beaucoup occupé nos
débats ces derniers jours sur l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes puisque
de l'étude d'impact que le ministère
lui-même publié il apparaît que les
femmes vont être davantage touchées que
les hommes en moyenne par la durée
l'augmentation de la durée du temps de
travail et monsieur le ministre vous
avez dit que ceux-ci ne creusait pas les
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes puisque et même que ça
rétablissait un certain nombre de choses
sous-entendu aujourd'hui ce sont plutôt
les femmes qui sont avantagées
puisqu'elles doivent travailler un peu
moins que les hommes et donc là elle va
devoir travailler un peu plus et ça
rétablirait un peu d'équité euh sachant
que en moyenne en France les femmes
touchent une retraite environ 40%
inférieur à celle des hommes est-ce que
vous considérez que aujourd'hui
les femmes ont un avantage indu en ce
qui concerne leur temps de travail et
les retraites et enfin je voulais juste
rebondir sur la question d'exposition au
substances chimique vous avez dit moi je
partage je préfère aussi que en fait
personne soit exposé à des substances
chimiques dangereuses plutôt que d'avoir
des personnes qui sont en mauvaise santé
et qu'on doit faire partir plus tôt
parce qu'elles sont mauvaise santé je
préfère que tout le monde soit une bonne
santé je voulais donc savoir si le
gouvernement avait prévu
des améliorations prochaines pour éviter
l'exposition aux substances chimiques
dangereuses des salariés afin que nous
n'ayons plus besoin d'avoir ce critère
je vous remercie
Corinne Ferret merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre à mon
tour de vous interroger pour ce moment
de d'audition sur des des points très
concrets viendra le temps du débat et
croyez moi on aura beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à dire sur cette réforme qui est
injuste qui est brutal et qui n'est pas
utile cela dit je voulais vous
interroger sur la pénibilité
vous avez il a été décidé en tout cas
dans cette réforme que les cotisations
vieillesse employeur serait augmenté et
qu'elle serait cette augmentation serait
compenser par une baisse du taux de
cotisation sur la branche accident du
travail maladie professionnelle la
première ministre ayant dit vous le
venez de le répéter que l'excédent de
cette branche était très important voire
très fort et qu'on pouvait ainsi agir
je rappelle
au préalable que cette branche est
constituée en tout cas les recettes de
cette branche sont constituées de 97% de
cotisations des entreprises comme son
nom l'indique accident du travail
maladie professionnelle ça se
contracte tout ça se passe en entreprise
ce n'est évidemment pas du fait du
salarié alors l'excédent vous avez
annoncé quelques chiffres moi je veux
aussi insister sur une partie et on en
parle à chaque examen du pfss sur le
volet sous déclaration on l'appelle
comme ça on constate que de nombreuses
déclarations
d'accidents du travail ne sont pas
faites ou réalisés en entreprise et pour
le coup elle bascule ou elles sont elles
relèvent à ce moment là de la branche
maladie je dis c'est sous déclarations
sont très fortes
puisque on considère là pour aujourd'hui
on va dire cette année passée donc on
est de l'ordre de 1 million deux à un
milliard deux à deux milliards d'euros
donc pour cela la branche ATMP reverse à
la branche maladie chaque année un
certain montant mais le gouvernement
depuis quelques années considèrent que
il faut se baser sur la fourchette basse
et non pas sur le fourchette hausse j'ai
souvenir dans nos débats de PNSS que
nous disions que ça ne devait pas
procéder ainsi mettre vraiment sur la
fourchette hausse haute et non pas comme
cela est proposé aujourd'hui donc cet
excédent moi je lui minerai
y compris au regard des chiffres que
vous avez vous avez de vous avez indiqué
et quand on parle d'excédent dans nos
débats
annuel sur le PLFSS et bien fort de ce
constat on va dire nous avons demandé
mais pas seulement notre groupe à la
fois que
puisque excédent il y a il y ait
beaucoup plus de crédit consacré à la
prévention des risques des risques
professionnels refuser qu'il n'y ait une
augmentation aussi des budgets consacrés
dédiés à l'anake l'agence nationale
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
c'est quand même pas rien et elle a un
rôle important qu'il n'y ait aussi une
augmentation des crédits ou des
financements pour les différents fonds
dédiés aux victimes que ce soit les
victimes de l'amiante les victimes du
chlore déconne et je me souviens en 2020
que nous avions déposé et discuter
débattus une proposition de moi pour la
création d'un fond covid qui bien
évidemment n'avait pas reçu le soutien
du gouvernement j'ai bien évidemment
parce que voilà les choses sont ainsi
donc voilà
comment cet excédent aussi pourrait être
utilisé je sais pas si c'est le terme
qui convient mais il n'y a véritablement
matière à
attribuer cette excédent à des besoins
qui sont réels alors vous dites que au
travers de cette réforme le gouvernement
se propose de faire plus encore voir
mieux sur la pénibilité mais je peux
vous rappeler la cruauté de vous
rappeler qu'en 2017 le gouvernement de
Monsieur Macron
s'est précipité on va dire pour retirer
quatre critères sur les 10 du compte
pénibilité et pas des moindres port de
charge lourdes d'exposition au
vibrations donc voilà de très nombreux
salariés sont confrontés à ces assez
difficultés de travail alors est-ce que
demain ou est-ce que dans cette réforme
que vous proposez puisque les choses
sont assez floues sur la pénibilité
est-ce que les quatre ces quatre
critères essentiels seront réintégrés
pour que tous les salariés qui sont
encore une fois qu'ils doivent y faire
face puissent
le valoriser on va dire au regard du
programme que vous proposez enfin il est
proposé aussi la création d'un fond d'un
milliard d'euros pendant le mandat pour
souscrire ou accompagner
on va dire ce soutien à la prise en
charge ou à la prise en compte ou à
l'évolution de la prise en compte de la
pénibilité
moi j'ai quelques inquiétudes où
interrogations on va dire au regard de
ce que j'ai précisé depuis tout à
l'heure
un excédent qui n'est pas à mon sens au
niveau que vous évoquiez une un
transfert sur la branche
maladie qui n'est pas au niveau
tel qu'il est il devrait être
qui est minorée là aussi même si à terme
se transfert ne devrait quasiment plus
exister c'est à dire que là aussi il y a
des actions d'information de
sensibilisation pour que toutes ces
déclarations relèvent bien de la branche
ATMP soit bien faite dans le cadre de
l'accident du travail maladie
professionnelle et non pas dans le cadre
d'un de la branche maladie voilà donc
mes questions mes interrogations pour ce
premier temps d'échange merci vraiment
de penser et Annick jacquemais et on en
aura terminé avec les questions vraiment
de penser oui merci Madame ma présidente
monsieur le ministre alors écoutez vous
entendre j'avais prévu des questions
mais je vais en faire d'autres parce que
je vous ai écouté attentivement et j'ai
remarqué tout comme je l'ai fait
remarquer ce matin lors de du rapport
sur le duo conseil des finances
publiques que vous avez un point aveugle
qui est assez intéressant c'est à dire
que vous dites la réforme va rapporter
18 milliards deux tiers on retrouve les
12 milliards de déficits sont affectés
au rétablissement des comptes de du des
retraites et puis bon prince vous un
tiers ira à l'amélioration toutes ces
améliorations dont je vous ai parlé et
qui sont souvent
tout simplement l'atténuation de la
brutalité de la réforme
mais il y a un point aveugle là qui
avez-vous fait des 3,9 milliards que
dont parle le corps qui dit que votre
retraite enfin induites par votre
réforme et notamment l'ouverture deux
ans après des droits de la retraite va
entraîner des dépenses de certaines
prestations à hauteur donc de 3,9
milliards ils sont où là dans votre
calcul je les vois plus j'ai pas eu la
réponse ce matin peut-être allez-vous me
la donner parce que je pense que le
tiers d'amélioration c'est aussi
c'est pas tout à fait de l'amélioration
ça doit être de pouvoir compenser
d'ailleurs on parle souvent d'un tiers
pour ses dépenses induites dans d'autres
branches effectivement que ce soit le
RSA pour les collectivités territoriales
ou que ça soit le chômage enfin ce qu'il
en reste puisque vous le réduisez
de réformes en réforme et
donc j'aimerais que vous me redonniez
alors pourquoi je dis ça parce que
effectivement 3,9 milliards c'est tout à
fait plausible pourquoi parce que vous
madame la rapporteur a dit votre votre
réforme est rapide moi je dirais qu'elle
est brutale parce qu'en fin de compte
sur qui va peser vont peser ces
économies elles vont peser sur la
tranche d'âge 55 61 ans ce qui devaient
partir vous savez ça commence c'est
cette année et alors qui sont ces 55 61
ans comment sont-ils aujourd'hui vous
savez très bien qui sont pour un quart
un fin pour une petite moitié encore un
emploi mais que effectivement un quart
n'est ni en emploi ni en retraite
cela vous sont-ils bien ils sont au RSA
ils sont en inactivité
où ils sont au chômage bien chômage il y
en a 10% qui sont au chômage dans ce que
je viens de dire et cela vos promesses
sur l'amélioration de la pénibilité sur
tout ce que vous allez faire pour les
seniors afin que le taux d'emploi soit
supérieur vous conviendrez que c'est pas
ceux qui ont 59 60 ans qui sont eux 20%
ni en emploi ni
en
retraite sur lequel ces fameuses
promesses que vous nous faites vont
s'appliquer donc cela vous le savez
c'est ces années enfin c'est trimestres
et ces années de prolongation c'est
l'allongement pour autant et à dû auteur
je dirais du sas de précarité où ils
sont d'autant plus le chômage a été
réduit de plusieurs mois vous savez que
cela ils ont un taux de retour à
l'emploi qui est catastrophique qui de
l'ordre de 30% et que ils font le gros
en gros ils sont du chômage de longue
durée parce qu'en fin de compte il
retrouve pas un emploi bien alors où
sont ces quatre milliards de qui en
quelque sorte consomment une partie du
bénéfice du bénéfice il y en a de la
retraite et d'ailleurs je note que 1/3
d'amélioration ce que vous dites le
fameux tiers
je vois que c'est les travailleurs quand
même qui se payent l'amélioration de
leur système il y a un partenaire là il
y a un acteur qui a disparu c'est
l'employeur quoi je croyais que la
retraite c'était du côté employeur du
côté salarié là c'est les salariés qui
bossent beaucoup plus pour se payer le
peu d'amélioration que vous avez
consenti
alors
par rapport à ça il y a un petit point
technique aussi que j'aimerais c'est par
rapport à ce qui a été dit sur
la cotisation ATMP qui passe
effectivement pour partir à la
vieillesse moi j'aimerais bien savoir si
c'est neutre pour l'employeur notamment
parce que je crois savoir quand même que
les cotisations vieillesse font l'objet
de large exonération patronales
et sociale et donc ils vont en
bénéficier pour 1,6 du SMIC etc alors
que la TMP ne bénéficiait d'aucune
exonération donc je moi je j'ai déjà
posé la question m'a pas répondu mais là
maintenant j'ai le ministre donc je
pense que lui il sait si c'est vraiment
neutre ou si effectivement par le biais
des exonérations d'un côté bon voilà
une dernière chose que je dirais c'est
que bon que vous soyez que nous nous
fassiez pour ne jamais solliciter
l'employeur c'est vrai que les
dividendes sont au plus bas les profits
aussi les profils du CAC 40 tout ça
c'est au plus bas il faut rétablir
effectivement seul partage des richesses
et très et très satisfaisant il s'est
dégradé maintenant il déstabilisé un
niveau dégradé donc vous parlez souvent
de compétitivité bon moi je ne crois pas
trop en tant qu'economiste à cet
argument je pense que c'est vraiment la
profitabilité que vous préservez là mais
vous parlez souvent quand même
pour ne pas augmenter les cotisations du
pouvoir d'achat alors moi j'aimerais
vous dire que autant vous pouvez parler
du côté de la compétitivité au nom des
employeurs que vous entendez très bien
et vous avez une oreille quand même bien
complaisante autant moi je vous demande
d'arrêter de parler au nom des salariés
parce que effectivement si vous leur
demandez si vous voulez les salariés
regarder les enquêtes quand même que et
y compris des enquêtes de cabinet très
libéraux
59% des Français seraient d'accord pour
une augmentation des cotisations pour
éviter votre réforme brutale
d'allongement du temps de travail selon
le baromètre de l'adresse 2021 plus de
trois personnes interrogées sur quatre
se disent opposés à la baisse des
prélèvements obligatoires quand de fait
elles sont associées à une baisse des
droits sociaux et c'est ce que vous avez
fait l'année dernière avec la loi du
pouvoir d'achat vous dites voir vous
vous payez pas de cotisation regardez là
sans localiser etc et tout mais vous
leur avez pas dit
quand ils ont 6000 jusqu'à 6000 de prime
des socialisés que
ils alimentent plus la caisse de
vieillesse et que il faudra quand même
qu'il travaille un peu plus longtemps
quoi et si vous leur aviez dit ça je
pense que il serait un peu moins
intéressé par ça voilà donc moi je pense
que il faut que vous regardiez vraiment
les sondages car les Français dans leur
grande majorité de toute façon ne
veulent plus qu'on arbitre si vous
voulez les gains de productivité en
faveur des du pouvoir d'achat ils
veulent enfin pour la partie qui je
parle pas bien sûr des des de la partie
la plus défavorisée ils veulent pouvoir
arbitrer les gains de productivité en
faveur aussi de leur temps libre en
faveur d'une meilleure articulation de
leur temps de travail en tant que
écologiste je vous dirais que si on
pour terminer monsieur le ministre vous
pourrez merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour vos
explications déjà moi j'ai été beaucoup
interpellée sur les règles qui régissent
la réversion des pensions de retraite et
la différence qu'il y a entre le secteur
privé et le secteur public alors dans le
secteur privé les salariés bénéficient
d'un taux de réversion qui est plus
avantageux
la pension de réversion du régime
général est égal à 54% de la pension de
l'assuré décédée 60% dans la plupart des
régimes complémentaires du privé contre
50% dans le secteur public par contre si
le défunt exerce une activité ou exercer
une activité dans le secteur privé les
pensions de réversion des époux
survivants sont soumis à des conditions
d'âge et de ressources qui n'existent
pas pour les fonctionnaires
d'une part concernant la condition de
ressources le conjoint survivant ne peut
pas prétendre recevoir de pension de
réversion si c'est revenu annuels sont
supérieurs à
2341,61 euros brut pour une personne
seule et
375006,56 € bruts pour une personne
vivant en couple et d'autre part
concernant la condition d'âge le
conjoint survivant sera privé de
l'intégralité de sa pension de réversion
si la moins de 55 ans alors pour
beaucoup de personnes que j'ai
rencontrées elles ont un grand sentiment
d'injustice donc je voulais vous
demander c'est quelque chose était prévu
un assouplissement une modification de
ses règles dans le dans le cadre des
textes qu'on va étudier et sinon est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas au moins modifier
l'effet de seuil dans le secteur
on envisageant pour plutôt un
pourcentage qu'un plafond de ressources
voilà merci merci
monsieur le ministre beaucoup de
questions
effectivement il y a quelques questions
que je vais
essayer d'aborder d'abord suivant
il revient pas je voudrais simplement
préciser que pour ce qui concerne la
pension minimum à l'issue d'une carrière
complète cotisée au niveau du SMIC nous
sommes bien et j'entends la difficulté
d'explication nous nous sommes bien sur
près 2200 euros brut ce qui correspond à
85% du SMIC net à la fin de l'année 2023
une fois qu'on a déterminé ce niveau de
pension brut en disant près de 1200
euros brut et cela dépendra en réalité
du montant exact du SMIC fin 2023 comme
cela dépendra du montant exact fin 2024
et ensuite année après année les seuls
prélèvements qui s'appliquent sur cette
pension consiste à la CSG et avec une
seconde précision à apporter qui tient
en fait que nous ne pouvons pas indiquer
individu par individu lorsque nous
sommes interrogés le pourcentage CSG qui
est appliqué puisqu'entre le toit zéro
le taux à 3,8 et le taux majoré cette
détermination du taux ne dépend pas
d'une guimau de la retraite mais du
niveau de ressources du foyer fiscal à
laquelle appartient à l'assuré nous
pouvons préjugés mais mais il y aura
toujours une exception nous pouvons
préjugé que les titulaires d'une pension
minimum telle qu'un si calculée à partir
de plus tôt généralement à des foyers un
sujet Tito à zéro auto à 3,8 mais il
peut toujours y avoir une exception et
on peut très bien imaginer qu'un assuré
ce bénéficiaire de la retraite minimum
tout en partageant sa vie avec un autre
assuré gagnant beaucoup plus d'argent et
amenant un assujettissement au taux
majoré sur la question de la durée de
cotisation je crois avoir répondu assez
largement à la question de Monsieur
vanderenberg tout à l'heure en répondant
aux trois rapporteurs sur le fait que
nous sommes dans une logique de
rapprochement au maximum des durées de
cotisations effectives de chacun des
assurés pour faire en sorte que cette
durée minimum de cotisations exigée par
nos textes ne soient pas exagérément
dépassé pour avoir accès à une retraite
à taux plein la mesure qui consisterait
à dire supp tel ou telle condition c'est
d'être très rapidement à plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros mais nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir dans le
débat il y a un lien
que vous avez souhaité ou en tout cas
sur lequel vous m'avez interrogé entre
la prise en compte nouvelle des trois
critères ergonomiques à la fois par la
mise en oeuvre d'accords de prévention
branche par branche puisque ce sont les
branches qui est des citrons qui est
discuteront les déciderons et le suivi
médical permettant des départs anticipés
le dispositif que nous proposons pour
les trois critères ergonomiques et
vraiment articulé autour de cela de la
prévention et un suivi médical pour un
départ anticipé sur avis médical si nous
faisions un lien comme monsieur le
sénateur le suggère entre ces trois
critères ergonomiques et le C2P cela te
dit dans d'autres interventions je crois
madame Ferrer ou madame l'humain
pardonnez-moi si je fais une confusion
cela consisterait à dire que
l'exposition à ces trois critères
ergonomiques serait pourvoyeuse de
points acquises au-dessus du C2P et avec
ces points qui ont du CVP on peut
obtenir des départs anticipés de droits
sans avis médical or et c'est là pour
dire la chose très clairement un point
désaccord que nous n'avons pas su
résoudre avec les organisations
syndicales réformistes en particulier
nous considérons que le dispositif que
nous proposons permet des départs
anticipés donc une forme de réparation
comme l'utilisation des points C2P en
tenant compte de l'effectivité de
l'exposition à ces trois critères
ergonomiques je prends un exemple pour
illustrer le propos l'expliquer lorsque
nous travaillons sur des métiers que
nous considérons comme très probablement
exposé à cette pénibilité liée aux trois
critères ergonomiques il y a fort à
parier que le métier de menuisier soit
exposé parce que si vous êtes menuisier
sur une charpente dans des chantiers
extérieurs exposés au froid au chaud et
à la manipulation directe évidemment que
le port de charge les vibrations les
postures pénibles sont au rendez-vous de
ce métier-là est nécessite une
réparation autant que nécessaire par
contre si vous êtes menuisier dans un
atelier avec parfois
une température contrôlée et en
utilisant une machine à commande
numérique l'exposition à la pénibilité
aux trois critères très différentes et
pourtant vous avez le même métier d'un
point de vue administratif et donc le
suivi médical renforcé individuel permet
de tenir compte de l'effectivité le
second exemple qui est souvent évoqué
même si ça reste un métier pénible dans
les deux cas à mes yeux concerne les
aides-soignante dans un EHPAD ou tous
les lits sont équipés de rails de leve
malade n'expose pas la même pénibilité
qu'être exprimant dans un EHPAD qui
dispose pas ses équipements et donc le
suivi médical permet aussi d'apporter
cette réponse différenciée en fonction
de l'effectivité des conditions de
travail sur la question des seniors et
de l'intégration des recettes et aux
emplois créés je vous confirme monsieur
le sénateur c'est bien intégré dans la
maquette financière les 300 000 que vous
avez évoqué sous la forme de
d'amélioration du niveau des recettes de
la CNAV enfin vous m'avez interrogé sur
deux choses la clause de revoyure est
les risques liés à l'article 40 pour ce
qui concerne la clause de revoyure je
pense que nous devons responsabilités
pour ce concerne le gouvernement et le
Parlement jugera adopter une trajectoire
de relèvement de l'âge qui permet
d'assurer l'équilibre à horizon 2030
après une fois que j'ai dit cela si le
Parlement et c'est son droit le plus
strict n'est même pas de question David
gouvernemental à leur matière si le
Parlement souhaite mettre en place des
modalités haddocks de suivi de la mise
en œuvre et les effets de la mise en
œuvre de la loi j'y seraient tout à fait
ouvert et le gouvernement il apportera
son concours j'ai notamment en tête ce
qui a été mis en place pour le suivi des
effets de la mise en œuvre du plan de
relance avec un comité Haddock
permettant d'éclairer les travaux et
d'avoir
un regard à la fois parlementaire et
extérieur sur les effets de ce plan de
relance sur l'article 40
la recevabilité au titre ou
l’irreçabilité au titre de l'article 40
au-delà du fait qu'elle n'appartient pas
au gouvernement bien évidemment ne
dépend pas de la nature du texte on
prend pas les fesses rectificatif ou un
projet de loi mais bien de la nature des
dépenses qui seraient proposées de leur
éligibilité vous me demandez de faire
preuve d'ouverture d'esprit ce n'est pas
une caractérise le plus mais
il y a un certain nombre de dispositions
qui évidemment
nécessiteront de faire preuve de cette
ouverture j'ai dit monsieur le sénateur
et je prends ce simple exemple à
l'occasion de réponse en commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale et hier lors des séances de
questions au Gouvernement devant la même
assemblée nationale que nous étions très
ouverts à des systèmes qui permettent de
faciliter le rachat de trimestre pour
études longues ou pour les stages en
période de formation et si je l'ai dit
c'était aussi pour que cette déclaration
publique que j'ai faite au nom du
gouvernement permette par anticipation
de lever les recevabilité au titre de
l'article 40 la démonstration nous
savons faire quand nous le souhaitons
pour permettre de donner un peu de marge
de manœuvre
au parlementaire c'est un début sur le
rapporteur c'est un début
madame Duba enfin m'a interrogé pardon
après et ensuite m'a interrogé sur la
nature du texte si nous avons retenu le
choix d'un pelfss rectificatif c'est
parce que l'ensemble des dispositions la
quasi totalité des disposition pardon
que nous présentons des impacts en
termes de coûts ou de recettes pour les
comptes sociaux et ainsi nous a paru
plus logique de le faire comme cela la
décote que vous dont vous appelez
l'aménagement et finalement déjà aménagé
d'une certaine manière par les
dispositions que nous proposons le fait
de maintenir là je suppression de la
décote à 67 ans soit 3 ans après le
nouvel âge d'ouverture des droits c'est
une première dans la mesure où chaque
relèvement de l'âge de départ c'était
accompagné d'un relèvement de l'âge de
suppression de la décote et ainsi avec
ce que nous proposons la décote qui
aujourd'hui peut atteindre 25% et limité
à 15 c'est un premier aménagement je
peux entendre que ça ne voit soit pas
suffisant à vos yeux mais je tenais à le
souligner parce que c'est aussi une
protection pour éviter d'aller trop loin
en termes d'âge pour celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas une carrière complète
sur la question des trimestres
d'apprentissage je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir mais je vois deux
questions derrière votre intervention la
première c'est si j'ai bien compris
est-ce que les trimestres
d'apprentissage réalisé avant 2014 et le
relèvement des rémunérations permettant
de fait d'être dans un niveau de
l'amélioration validant un trimestre
pourrait être pris en compte en fait il
y a deux possibilités soit les apprentis
en question par le nombre d'heures sur
lequel ils ont payé des cotisations et
le niveau de rémunération on cotisait à
hauteur de 150 heures par trimestre au
niveau du SMIC de l'époque et ça
nécessite de reconstituer les carrières
il y a une seconde possibilité qui est
moins
qui est moins positive enfin je ne sais
pas si je vais le dire comme ça mais qui
est moins attrayante qui est d'autoriser
de faciliter le rachat de trimestre
réalisé au titre de l'apprentissage
lorsque ceux-ci n'ont pas donné lieu à
cotisation ou sur des niveaux de
cotisations très bas ça fait partie des
choses que l'on peut aussi regarder pour
faciliter notamment dans le cas
d'apprentis qui dans certaines
situations il a fort longtemps
maintenant pouvait être rémunérés sur
des montants de rémunération très très
bas très très basse mais en tout cas
c'est quelque chose que l'on peut
regarder en fonction des périodes et des
reconstitutions de carrière
sur la bonification pour
enfants et le fait qu'aujourd'hui il y a
quatre trimestres dans le régime général
alors que ces deux dans le régime public
je suis très ouvert je l'ai dit cet
après-midi parce qu'il y a une réflexion
sur les droits familiaux de manière
générale est-ce que je dis là est vrai
pour les pensions de reversion ça
renvoie à votre intervention je crois
madame pensez bon je madame non pardon
madame Jacques mais pardonnez-moi parce
que il y a trop de différence sur les
seules pensions de réversion il y a 13
régimes qu'il y a un cas de dépensions
de réversion et derrière ce nombre de
régime il y a autant d'injustices et
d'inégalités c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous en avons saisi le corps
mais c'est aussi je pense un sujet que
nous aurons beaucoup de profits à
regarder ensemble sur la base initiative
et de travaux parlementaires
sur la question du niveau minimum de
pension comme j'ai dit à Monsieur Savary
tout à l'heure ça n'est pas une
allocation ou une garantie
différentielle tout régime c'est le
relèvement du minimum contributif et
donc ce que nous proposons
d'accord mais il n'y a pas de souci mais
comme par ailleurs madame l'Huma m'avait
aussi interrogé je réponds tout aussi
directement sur le minimum de pension
c'est un relèvement du minimum
contributif et nous ont le choix de le
relever de 75 euros le minimum
contributif majoré qui est accessible
pour tout assurer ayant
cotisé 120 trimestres à l'échelle de sa
carrière c'est à dire 30 ans et de 25
euros du minimum contributif de base
c'est un mix pardon pour la mauvaise
expression qui permet de couvrir le plus
de monde possible et ça permet notamment
de couvrir les carrières hachées puisque
ça permet l'accès à tout ou partie de
cette valorisation pour des carrières
qui n'auraient pas été intégralement
complète mais qui aurait connu pour la
majeure partie de la revalorisation au
moins 30 ans de cotisations
alors pour les carrés complexes c'est
100 euros
et ça permet de passer d'environ
1060.163 euros aujourd'hui à
1170 euros aujourd'hui 1193 euros dans
nos prévisions en septembre ça me permet
de répondre indirectement à Madame Vogel
7 euros on sait que ça compte et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle vous
avez certainement noté que j'ai toujours
pris la précaution de dire une retraite
minimale une minimum près de 1200 euros
parce que je sais pertinemment qu'on
était plutôt autour de 1190 1193 non il
n'y a pas de dispositifs il y en a qu'un
articulé autour du minimum contributif
mais avec une revalorisation du myco
majoré pour 75 euros pour une carrière
complète cotise au niveau du SMIC et de
25 euros pour le minimum contributif
général de base pardon qui lui est plus
facilement accessible ce qui permet
d'amener des revalorisations à des
personnes qui ont des carrières très
incomplètes puisque non assujetti à
cette obligation de 120 trimestres
cotisés à l'échelle de l'année j'espère
avoir été
puisque la pension c'est 1200 euros brut
et c'est ainsi qu'on arrive à 1200 euros
brut sur lequel s'applique le taux de
CSG tel que j'avais évoqué ensuite dans
Madame Vogel j'ai répondu sur le prêt de
1200 euros et pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
confusion sur l'importance des 7 euros
oui mais elle avait aussi posé la
question des 7 euros voilà sur les 1200
euros je ne sais pas le dire précisément
je sais que le système que nous
proposons ce que j'ai dit dans mon
propos liminaire permet de revaloriser
la pension et la petite pension d'une
certaine manière de 200 000 nouveaux
assurés par an c'est-à-dire un départ
sur 4 pour un montant qui va varier de
25 ou 30 euros jusqu'à 100 euros mais je
n'ai pas la ventilation dont je préfère
en la matière ne pas vous donner un
chiffre trop précis qui serait pas
nature une erreur puisque je n'ai pas
cette ventilation avec moi à l'instant
où je joue pas madame la sénatrice m'a
demandé si je considérais que les
trimestres validé au titre de la
maternité provoquait un avantage induit
je pense qu'on peut avoir un débat très
apaisé sur la question des droits
familiaux et de leur harmonisation en
écho à ce que j'ai dit à l'instant à
Madame Lubin sur les quatre trimestres
concernant la validation des trimestres
de maternité sans être dans une forme de
caricature ou de procès d'intention il
n'y a pas davantage indus
il y a une situation que l'on peut dire
très calmement aussi et ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il fallait remettre en cause qui
est que la validation de quatre
trimestres pour les femmes à l'occasion
d'une maternité était pensé pour
compenser des trimestres non travaillés
du fait de la rédactivité et donc de
l'arrêt de cotisation le temps d'élever
un enfant est plutôt à l'échelle d'une
année et aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
une situation où pour une femme qui
connaît la maternité qui est indemnisé
au titre de l'assurance maladie pour le
congé maternité il y a finalement sur
l'année de naissance de l'enfant la
possibilité de valider quatre trimestres
comme toute personne en activité auquel
s'ajoute de valider et de cotiser ce qui
est trimestre auquel s'ajoute quatre
trimestres de majoration et auxquels
peuvent s'ajouter quatre trimestres
supplémentaires puisqu'on dit toujours 4
pour le régime général mais en fait
c'est 4 + 4 sachant que les + 4 peuvent
être répartis librement entre les
parents mais qu'à défaut de répartition
volontaire avant les quatre ans de
l'enfant ils sont attribués
automatiquement à la mer et donc on est
dans une situation nous avons
cette différence d'âge effectif de
départ qui s'explique par le fait qu'à
carrière
du fait de validation trimestre
concomitant à la validation à la
cotisation de trimestre par activité il
y a une possibilité il y a une
possibilité nous constatons un départ
plus jeune des femmes par rapport aux
hommes et la réforme telle que nous
l'apportons à la fois par l'effet
qu'elle a et je souscris à la
démonstration sur ce point de Madame la
scénariste vosgel par le relèvement de
l'âge de départ mais aussi par la mise
en œuvre de la réforme de 2013 amenant
une augmentation de la durée de
cotisation ces deux réformes conjuguées
font que il y aura un rapprochement de
l'âge effectif de départ et que la
différence de 6 mois que nous constatons
avec un âge de départ effectif des
femmes inférieur de celui des hommes de
6 mois va plutôt être autour de deux
mois à horizon 2030 c'est ce qui m'a
amené à dire cet après-midi que les
femmes ne travailleraient pas plus tard
ni plus longtemps que les hommes même
avec l'application de cette réforme et
cette réforme a aussi des effets en
termes de pension puisque pour la
génération 72 qui a été évoquée nous
estimons que le niveau moyen de
revalorisation des pensions permis par
la réforme de manière intrinsèque est
autour de 650 euros par an et que 30% de
femmes environ d'assurer femme femme
assurée pardonnez-moi auront une
revalorisation de leur pension du fait
de la réforme et c'est justice quand on
sait l'écart de pension que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui enfin madame la
sénatrice avait une dernière question
sur les risques chimiques je fais vite
puisque là j'aurai l'occasion à mon avis
d'en reparler avec elle mais je voulais
évoquer avec elle les valeurs limites
d'exposition professionnelle telle que
définie par l'Union européenne qui pose
un cadre particulièrement protecteur et
auquel évidemment nous nous souscrivons
et dans lequel nous convergons
sur la question de Madame Ferret
concernant le swap pardon aussi pour cet
anglicisme entre la CNAV et la TMP pour
nous il s'agit bien de mesures qui sont
importantes puisque aujourd'hui la TP la
branche ATMP consacre environ 40
millions d'euros par an à la prévention
de la pénibilité et donc un milliard
d'euros sur le quinquennat et ça peut
être autour de 200 250 millions d'euros
par an donc on est sur un vrai
changement d'échelle en termes de
financement des actions de prévention de
la pénibilité et il faut ajouter à ce
milliard d'euros le fait que nous créons
un fond de 100 millions d'euros par an
donc 500 millions sur le quinquennat
pour financer le fond de prévention pour
la pénibilité des carrières de soignants
et c'est porté dans le PLFSS et avec la
volonté d'apporter des réponses très
particulières aux métiers des aides
soignants des infirmiers et mes
collègues en charge de ces sujets vont
ouvrir une discussion avec les
employeurs territoriaux pour voir
comment on peut imaginer un fonds de
prévention de la pénibilité dans la
fonction publique territoriale qui
permettent de prévenir puisqu'on sait
notamment pour les catégories C de la
fonction publique territoriale les
départs anticipés pour incapacité ou une
aptitude sont plus importants
pourcentage et en volume que dans
d'autres métiers qu'ils soient public ou
privés et donc ça ne s'arrête pas un
milliard l'action pour la pénibilité ça
ne remet pas du tout en cause le fait
que la branche estmp puisse fonctionner
je disais tout à l'heure et je ne
partage pas votre inquiétude sur la
minoration des transferts vers la CNAM
mais dans les prévisions que nous avons
les 3,3 milliards d'excédents 2026 sont
après les transferts de 1 milliard un
milliard deux ça dépend des années qui
sont votés en PLFSS ces 3 milliards 3
peuvent évidemment absorber 200 millions
d'euros par an de prévention pénibilité
et si nous diminuions de 1 milliard
d'euros il reste encore de milliards 2
milliards sur une branche qui gère 17
milliards d'euros sinon nous ne faisons
rien ça peut être vite comme très bien
mais peut-être inutile
si nous ne faisons rien de ce que nous
prévoyons la branche ATMP serait
excédentaire à hauteur de 20% de ses
recettes annuelles ce qui est un
excédent assez
inutile finalement en matière de
protection sociale il vaut mieux
mobiliser ses fonds pour pouvoir avancer
sur les interventions de madame poncemon
je tiens vous rassurer madame la
sénatrice les dépenses induites nous les
connaissons bien puisque tous les
chiffres que vous avez évoqués viennent
des services du ministère du travail
tant pour le chômage pour ce qui
concerne la daresque pour la maladie
pour ce qui concerne l'adresse et dans
les mesures d'accompagnement que j'ai
évoqué
le fait de maintenir l'âge de départ à
taux plein sans décote à 62 ans pour les
personnes qui partent pour incapacité ou
une aptitude à 55 ans pour les
travailleurs handicapés c'est justement
ce qui nous permet d'éviter cet effet de
transfert que vous évoquez puisque dans
toutes les réformes précédentes et
c'était le cas de la réforme de 2010 le
relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits c'était accompagné d'un
relèvement de l'âge de départ sans
décote pour ses catégories de population
dites fragiles le fait de ne pas le
faire évite l'effet induits sur les
autres branches telles que nous avons pu
le constater dans le bilan d'application
de la réforme de 2010 et donc c'est
d'ores et déjà intégré dans notre
maquette notamment pour les questions
relatives au chômage et à l'assurance
maladie et je vous assure aussi nous
avons tenu compte de l'assiette et de
l'existence d'allègement en matière de
cotisation CNAV pour que la neutralité
soit bien présente dans un sens comme
dans l'autre et que ça ne coûte pas plus
aux employeurs mais que ça ne leur coûte
pas moins et enfin je termine madame la
Présidente mais j'ai répondu très
rapidement tout à l'heure pour dire à
Madame Jacquemet que la totalité de son
propos
concernant les pensions de réversion est
juste et que ça nécessite ce travail
très approfondi je forme simplement le
vœu que l'examen parlementaire nous
permet peut-être d'améliorer la
situation et la prise en compte de cette
situation moins nombreuses mais
peut-être très injuste je pense
notamment aux possibilités de
d'attribution de pension de réversion
aux orphelins en particulier aux
orphelins handicapés qui sont dans une
situation souvent dramatique et ça je
pense que nous pouvons trouver des
consensus et je l'espère les construire
sans attendre ce travail plus global sur
les droits familiaux que ce soit en
termes d'accompagnement de la maternité
de la parentalité et la question des
réversions pour répondre à des
situations plus compliquées que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui que l'on peut
réparer voilà je ne sais pas si j'ai
répondu absolument tout mais j'aurai
l'occasion je pense dans le débat de
revenir sur ces questions là
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci en
effet pour répondre de façon précise à
des questions complexes alors on peut ne
pas c'est le cas pour certains être
d'accord mais néanmoins nous vous
remercions de prendre le temps
nécessaire pour répondre de façon le
plus documentée possible à toutes les
questions que l'on vous pose et nous
vous donnons rendez-vous au débat